so let's talk about some icons of
daytime TV okay there's only ETS
flashing back and getting the set see
that you all never knew as we kick off
talk-show Titans week with the host to
name is also a change you ready for this
yeah yeah Jerry Jerry Jerry DD is just a
regular schmegle oh ho I knew going in
every day they were gonna hand me a
circus so I couldn't pretend to be upset
about it with more than 50,000 guests in
nearly 4,000 episodes in 27 years
Jerry pulled in all the college kids
with shows like my ex still wants my sex
you slept with my stripper sister and
naked peekaboo baby you know I love you
people obviously enjoyed it or they
wouldn't have launched and people enjoy
being on they volunteer to be on they
call us you can't call someone and say
hey will you be on the Jerry Springer
Show they say they'd hang up on you a
few secrets potential guests were given
a free flight in hotel stay to get them
to appear on the show and those fights
were staged sorta just before cameras
rolled producers got guests angry and
excited to ensure a confrontation would
happen so just how did Jerry a former
lawyer and mayor of Cincinnati end up
with his own talk show I was assigned to
it and the company there owned our
station own talk shows Phil Donahue
Sally Jessy Raphael Phil was getting
ready for retirement the CEO took me to
lunch one day and said we're starting
another talk show and you're gonna be
the host could never be as good as Oprah
I could never you know be filled on to
you and they're probably very happy that
they can go through life saying it
provide and influence them now at the
age of 75 Springer is going in an
entirely new direction judge Terry next
time that happens column over the first
grown-up job offend 30 years
I mean hosting the Jerry Springer shows
a lot of fun but adults could do it to
be a talk show host you only needs three
lines you did what
come on out we'll be right back
if you can do those three lines you got
a show
[Music]
[Applause]